>> The first graph was correct. let's see why. Let's solve this inequality for y
so we can get the boundary line. First, we subtract 4 x from both sides, then we
divide each term by 3 to get y is greater than or equal to negative 4 3rd x plus
4. This inequality is in slope intercept form so I can graph the line that
represents the boundary. The y-intercept is 4, and my slope is negative 4 3rd.
Down 4, right 3. That will get me to my next point. This is the boundary line
for the inequality. I draw it solid, because the symbol is greater than or equal
to. So, points on this line do satisfy this inequality. Next, I choose a test
point, like the origin, to determine which region to shade. This region or this
region. Plugging in zero for x and zero for y, I get, 0 is greater than or equal
to 4. We know this is not true. So, points in this region do not satisfy the
inequality. We want points in this region, so we shade above. Amazing work if
you got that one right.